let's begin with the ex I 2.0 today's  agreement means that we are delivering  on one of our top priorities the outside  2.0 aims to mobilize private and public  investment worth 500 billion euro until  2020 and push forward number of  improvements second highlight of today's  meeting was the so-called attitude anti  tax avoidance directive focusing on  hybrid mismatches with third countries  EU has a strong framework in place to  maintain stability I was able to confirm  todays at the bank recovery and  resolution directive and Deposit  Guarantee Scheme director had been  transposed by all member states we're  delighted ministers gave their go ahead  for new legislation that will ensure tax  authorities in the you can access data  collected under current  anti-money-laundering rules